rusia dejó la pelota en el lado de los
países occidentales aliados en la otan
previo a un nuevo encuentro del llamado
cuarteto de normandía la portavoz del
ministerio de relaciones exteriores ruso
dejó clara sus peticiones para
desescalar el conflicto
es posible lograr una desescalada de la
situación en ucrania para hacerlo es
necesario detener la entrega de armas a
ucrania retirar los asesores e
instructores militares de su territorio
detener los ejercicios conjuntos de las
fuerzas armadas de ucrania y los países
de la otan y stan la está rusia y
ucrania han vivido una atención casi
permanente agudizada en 2014 por la
anexión de la península de crimea por
parte de moscú y las denuncias de kiev
de que el kremlin respaldó a grupos
rebeldes en el territorio del donbass
ahora el despliegue de tropas rusas en
la frontera con ucrania ha encendido las
alarmas en occidente por una posible
invasión a territorio ucraniano y ha
generado preocupación entre los
ucranianos que se manifestaron en kiev
frente a la embajada estadounidense para
pedir una solución pacífica
y pedimos a los diplomáticos que ayuden
a resolver el conflicto con rusia de una
manera pacífica para que no haya una
acción militar en territorio ucraniano y
para poder vivir en paz
la reunión del formato de normandía en
berlín coincide con el inicio de una
serie de ejercicios militares conjuntos
entre rusia y belarús que se extenderán
hasta el 20 de febrero ya los que
ucrania responderá con ensayos de
equipos militares mientras sigue
arribando a su territorio ayuda de
países aliados de la otan para
fortalecer su defensa